it's so funny because I tweeted
yesterday that I was having you on and I
happened to be watching Bernie speak and
I took a picture of Bernie speaking in
the background about income inequality
then I had your book in the foreground
and then I tweeted that you were on and
then people immediately and I'm very
proud that we've created something good
here because I have a lot of people on
the left and I have a lot of people on
the right and I'm trying to get these
people together right and then have the
causation and let them have the
conversation and then and then we'll see
and look people will respond in the
comment section to this and they'll say
either well I agree with x and y and I
disagree with this or whatever but
immediately a bunch of people jumped on
yes and it was and I was watching the
the back-and-forth and you were doing it
I try not to do the back and forth I'm
Twitter that much anymore but you were
doing it and you were trying to calmly
well read this they were jumping on you
baby you try this read this or maybe you
misunderstand that and that's where we
all have to get if we're gonna move
I said of course it's very hard to do in
Twitter it's unbelievably frustrating
because Twitter you know you got this
character limit yeah I have to make it
snappy and catchy and you can't have a
rational conversation on Twitter this is
why I try to say please read the book or
read this article here's a link to a
video and you know because you can't
articulate any kind of case on this but
I mean what what we are trying to do is
make this a philosophical debate and and
the problem is this today and it's one
of my exchanges with one of you
I think audience followers what was
about this his viewers philosophies
useless philosophy is a waste of time
it's just it's completely arbitrary it's
just people rambling right and that's to
some extent true mana philosophy is
completely useless completely rambling
it's detached from reality what I'm
trying to suggest is there's an
alternative view first of all we all
have a philosophy whether we like it or
not whether we know it or not whether we
articulate it on we're all guided by a
philosophy but secondly there is the
alternative philosophies that approach
science that appro reason the pro fact
they're so useless floating abstractions
detached from reality philosophy that so
many people have abandoned it and that's
sad to me it's very sad because I want
them engaged in a debate particularly
those who oppose science the
I don't want size versus philosophy I
want them to try to think what kind of
philosophy is they that is supportive
and enhancing of science it's no
accident that science a scientific
revolution happens when it does it
happens when the West rediscovers Greek
philosophy and it's no accident that
Greece is that is the start of science
because they philosophically they viewed
philosophy as a tool to understand
reality and they you know I just started
created the scientific method he made a
lot of mistakes in science huge mistakes
inside sure but the method he got it was
an empirical method of testing and
observation and it was because he was
guided by a particular philosophy that
allowed him to do that it was because in
the Renaissance in the end and late in
the Enlightenment we had a respectful
for reason and for our senses that
science could develop to the to if you
abandoned philosophy you will ultimately
abandon science right so using the
example of Greece
you must find modern-day Greece to be a
very depressing example of using
philosophy properly because I guess you
would argue they abandoned it because
they have all kinds of problems
economically but it's you it's mostly
because they went with more left-wing
policies well so again
yes it's left-wing policies but lefting
policies are driven by philosophical
approach so I view this as I Rand and
and and other thinkers within
objectivism something you know view all
of history as in a sense of battle
between Aristotle and Plato and you can
find all the bad policies that Greece
that we that that you know even even
emotionalism all of those linked back to
Plato and all the good stuff leagues now
Stano scientific revolution the
Enlightenment the the the America as a
free country are all in there is to tell
you tradition and there's a constant
philosophical fight going on Plato
believed that we all live in a cave that
we don't know real reality and we need
philosopher Kings who somehow commune
with the world of forms to know what the
truth is
so you need a pope to talk to God to
tell us the truth Oh
you need leaders right whether the
tribal leaders whether the political
leaders who know what's good for all of
us because we are still in a cave and we
don't know what's good right that's
where thelet Arianism and modern kind of
democracy comes from as thought I
believe that each one of us has the
capacity to reason for himself and that
the purpose of morality
Aristotle's very similar to Iran here
the purpose of morality firestar oh it's
the guide us towards eudaimonia which is
flourishing so individual flourishing
and then you know while i might disagree
with the particular things that he
advised people to do in order to achieve
happiness the goal is the same now it's
just a scientific question what actually
leads to human flourishing right so okay
so for the Plato version of this of your
inner cave basically it's saying that we
need we need somebody upstairs whether
it either a religious figure I said over
the Pope or just people that we elect or
submarines and yeah those terminology
some leader too because we can't do it
ourselves now obviously I buy into the
aristotle version of this but i think
what a lot of people would say is well
if everyone is doing what they think is
best for themselves this is this is the
main critique I've heard I was watching
you once on John Stossel on Fox Business
I think and somebody was was asking you
about this but if everyone is doing what
they think is best for themselves that
that really is anarchy well but it's not
cuz the caveat in that is what's good
for you is not to exploit other people
exploiting other people is bad for you
right and and I have whole seminars on
why lying stealing cheating it is just
bad for you it's destructive to your own
soul your own ability to communicate
with other people and also we have to
realize what's doing good for you means
being rational about it right reason is
the fundamental so you really have to
think I tell people if you want to be
selfish in the way Iran talks about
selfishness right if you really want to
do what's good for you
it's hard work think about it most
people think oh being selfish is like
what a two-year-old does and I'm saying
no a two-year-old doesn't know what he's
doing
right it's just guided by emotion they
don't have the frontal cortex that's not
developed enough for them to reason
themselves into self-interest right
self-interest requires thought it will
quite figuring out okay I've got 50
to live if you're young right what is
the best path for me to take what are
the choices I should make is honesty
dishonesty make sense not as a
commandment fall above not as is
something that society tells me but does
honesty make sense for me and I would
argue absolutely it's right you know
being dishonest it's just stupid policy
it's really really bad for you if you
think about it as rationale long to him
self-interest and if we're all
rationally long to himself interested
there's no clash there's no I mean we're
not trying to exploit what is the
relationship people have with one
another if they're pursuing their own
self-interest it's trade I want you to
be successful because when you're
successful you're producing creating
values that make me more successful I
love Apple because I get a buy an iPhone
for 300 bucks and it's made my life
significantly better and it much worth
much more to me than 300 bucks
Apple won I won I love my wife because
you know my life is better because of
having a relationship with her her life
is better I hope for me right right so
all of life for a rationally
self-interested human being is about
win-win relationship this is another
thing I hate about Trump Trump views
life in terms of winners and losers I
view life in terms of winners and
winners right and and yet we're not
gonna win at the same rate right some of
us will be incredibly successful but
then also what does success mean I mean
I find it interesting that the left
always measures success in terms of
dollars and I don't measure success in
terms of dollars I I chose to be a
teacher I could have gone to Wall Street
because I love what I do and this is
this is much more fun than having
millions of dollars in the bank ego Yeah
right so it's about having a great life
it's not about how many dollars you
accumulate and we're all gonna we all
have the opportunity to win and it's not
when you win it's not if somebody's
expense it's the opposite the only way
to make money the only way to be
successful is to provide a value to
somebody else right so that's really
interesting so that you'd say that the
left would look at this and say well
this just this is just unleashing the
chains unshackling people to be purely
selfish but really what you're saying is
if you were left to your own devices to
their own devices
it's not that you just want to be
selfish just to make money because you
also want the people around you to be
happy and you want your family to be
happy and you want your community to be
better and people are operating under
this idea without even realizing it yeah
absolutely but but I mean let's be clear
I'm not saying that if you just
unleashed everybody tomorrow everybody
would rationally self-interested right
there are genuinely bad Peter generally
bad people and then there's some people
who just don't think and therefore will
do stupid things yeah they did it today
they'll continue to do them but what
you're giving is the opportunity for
people who want to be rational who want
to pursue a good life the opportunity to
do it now one of the things you have to
teach people is how to be Moll I I'm all
for model education mm-hmm but what
morality boils down for me is teach them
how to think how to think not just about
science not just about the world out
there but think about what about
themselves what's good for me what's not
good for me
what will lead to a flourishing life
won't lead to a flourishing life so
rather than today self-interest is
associated with doing whatever you feel
like doing it so there's a line of
cocaine there I'm gonna get a high
that's in my self-interest right and I'm
going no it's not if you know anything
about cocaine of people who take it
regularly its destructive to your life
don't do it so you have a right to do it
right a political right cuz you're not
coercing anybody by taking the cocaine
but do you have a but should you do it
from our perspective and I'm saying no
not because you're gonna hurt somebody
else but but you're hurting yourself the
most valuable thing you have is you yeah
so don't hurt yourself that's why so so
yes pursue yourself interest but do it
rationally with your long-term interests
in mind okay so everything that you've
said so far about 40 minutes in I'm
pretty much with you this is where my
evolution has been good so why have
these ideas haven't why haven't these
ideas had better sellers where are the
merit of where where's the iron rand of
today I mean obviously this is what you
are doing and there's plenty of people
that I think are more libertarian like
Penn Jillette and Michael Shermer and
some other people I know that are
selling these ideas but where are the
people going man take your life back and
live for yourself and through that you
will
you will make the world a better place
they don't exist and or there very few
of us and the reason is I think is is
what we talked about education I think
educational system is destroyed that
where is where the where the great
economist I mean where's the Milton
Friedman I mean we would talk about the
minimum wage that Milton Friedman were
alive today he would be on every TV show
would be every way explaining this and
it nobody does it or take Donald Trump's
claims about trade which are ludicrous
and Bernie Sanders of course agrees with
him they're ludicrous that any economist
would say and there's nobody nobody
defending them except I so really good
editorial from a guy who I hate to say
wrote a really good at oh but you did
Alan Blinder way disagrees on almost
everything in economics and he wrote
this really good op-ed about free trade
now where's the Milton Friedman doing
that you know we just we lack and and I
I don't know as much about science but I
fear that we we just don't have the the
Einsteins and the Newton's and the and
the Darwin's right I just think that we
are much more mediocre today than we
were in terms of geniuses and maybe our
genius is going to business and the
Steve Jobs is of the world but we don't
seem to have those bigger than life you
know same with novelists with the Victo
who go up today I just don't see those
kind of people and I think we've
averaged down in the name by the way
it's related to the book right I think
in the name of equality I think that's
one of the evils of equality is it
averages this down not only on economic
tones but it tries to have it just down
on everything right so it fully explains
the Trump thing I mean everything you're
saying explains the trumping because
we've we've dumbed ourselves down we
want easy answers and then he gets up
there and he explains some of these
traits up so okay so just for the trade
stuff real quick without without making
you you know fully explain all of your
policies when he says simple things like
we're you know we've had bad trade deals
and we're gonna have better trade deals
and all that I think a lot of people
watch it me to eat to a some degree I
watch and I go well this is a guy who's
a businessman and I get it he's used the
bankruptcy laws to an advantage he sells
ties and other places also do his
advantage
he might be agree might be a great
businessman being a good businessman
doesn't mean you know anything right and
he doesn't so so but when he says that
stuff yeah do you
so you just think it's complete nonsense
that he can't negotiate trade deals any
better because that's just simply not
there is no such thing as a negotiated
better trade deal the best trade policy
and look Adam Smith wrote about this in
the wealth of nation 200 in 1776 right
now
Ricardo wrote about this in the 19th
century there is no economist left or
right almost no economist cuz there's
always some wackos but there's no
economist left all right this is why
Alan Blinder wrote about this right he's
a leftist economist he's a Keynesian I
disagree with him on so much but there's
almost no economist who doesn't believe
that the best trade policy for the
United States from our wealth maximizing
for Americans for individual Americans
is zero tariffs just take tariffs in
America and put them at zero and let the
rest of the world do whatever the hell
they want now for those countries for
China the best trade policy's is for
them to lower it to 0 and if we lowered
it to zero they would they would have
lots of pressure internally to lords so
I'm against trade deals right because I
think we should just do it ourselves now
some people gonna suffer as a
consequence within you know say sure
some people lose their jobs and they're
gonna have to figure out new jobs but
other jobs will be created and the net
effect clearly again shown by economists
for 200 plus years is that the US
economy and individuals within the u.s.
become richer wealthier more successful
it's the same as if a plant leaves
California and goes to Nevada do we get
all that pop like take about oh my god
how often no I mean they made that they
made the decision it's cheap over there
the fact is that you know in this case
we can import the stuff from Nevada
import it right we don't even think in
those terms the the stuff is gonna be
cheaper producing Nevada so therefore
will buy it for cheaper we'll have more
money to consume on other things or ass
it god forbid save in America we don't
believe in that anymore but save some
money invest it and create the kind of
businesses where we in America have a
comparative advantage look a hundred
years ago 80% of American population
worked in farming today less than 1%
does and we produce much more food than
ever before and eat by by a long shot
in 1979 manufacturing jobs peaked in the
United States we have half the number of
manufacturing
we produce more stuff than we ever have
ever most of that has nothing to do with
China
anybody else most that's automation so
it's just science and technology has
changed the world and new jobs and new
jobs are going to be out there and it's
not just science and technology
globalization has changed so well but
that's great a billion people a billion
people have come out of poverty in Asia
over the last thirty years that's a
billion people to me we should be
celebrating dancing in the streets
nobody talks about it because they came
out of poverty not because of a foreign
aid they came out of poverty because
those countries adopted a little bit of
free markets and because there's the
perception that they did it and we lost
jobs to some extent that's true but we
gained more jobs than we lost the fact
is that it then when trade is free in
America unemployment is very very low